Candace Owens wants to bring back a form
of eugenics where you breed children to
be better at math the way you might
breed a dog to be more or less
aggressive or have different coloring on
its fur this is absolutely and utterly
insane stuff is it Nazi stuff is it not
I mean you you tell me here is Candace
Owens explaining the South Koreans are
breeding for math skills we should have
a breeding program so yes it is correct
to say that these dogs or bred to fight
they were bred to attack and they were
bred to kill over many many years and
the question of whether or not breeding
works of course it does the question of
whether or not Darwinism is real of
course it is you can breed for Heights
you can breed for intelligence you can
breed for stupid if you there's
something about the use of the word
breeding that is like extremely icky
really want to right obviously this can
take place you can breathe for
athleticism we see examples of this all
the time but it's important to note yeah
that just because you are bred in one
way or the other does not mean that you
are locked into that permanent state
right so right now uh the most
mathematically capable people in the
world are Koreans does it mean that
Koreans are forever going to be the most
mathematically capable people in the
world we could start breeding Americans
do better at math we could start doing
what they do over in Korea
um or we could not you mean having
education that works and we can remain
probably the dumbest mathematical
country in the world okay so the the the
I don't know that the funny is the right
word but the ironic thing here is
Candace has almost got it she's she's
almost got it you don't have to breed
children for math just educate them
educate the people that we have now why
wait to have a multi-generational
breeding program for math educate people
now we could better fund education which
she's against many of her cohort want to
eliminate the department of energy many
of her cohort want to teach creationism
in science class along the theory of
evolution
they are doing the dumbing down they
want to get rid of a whole bunch of
books they want to require things be in
the curriculum that aren't going to make
anybody better at math she's against all
of that stuff we should be better at
math we also shouldn't be teaching
creationism in science class and you
know she goes to the South Koreans are
bred to be good at math
it is widely
studied that there are a number of Asian
cultures that focus on and emphasize
Scholastic Excellence among their young
when schools are when well-funded and
well supported and teachers are
appropriately paid and they can that
allows the attraction of better teachers
to the job
they're against all of the stuff breed
you know it's like she's going Eugenics
where what you need to do is you need to
fund education and it's the similar sort
of thing what you know some some of
these folks they uh they they like to
talk about
um you know what actually I don't even
need to give other examples these these
really stand on their own she's almost
got it why aren't we creating an
environment in which students are better
at math well a lot of it is not about
genetics it's about her movement saying
do all of these things which weakens
education and and it's
it's frustrating to see that she's so
close but the narrow worldview won't let
her realize oh wait maybe like all the
stuff I say about defunding public
schools isn't going to get us to what we
need
um I don't know that she's ready to to
deal with that but she's of the mindset
of we've got a problem let's use
Eugenics to fix it we don't have to wait
that long we can fix it right now with
education